hallo mein name ist willkommen heute ist
mein buch herausgekommen morgen raus ich
drum corps aber gerade nicht hier also
schild kurs ich hole das eben
und hier ist es auch schon ein buch das
ist das ist mein buch ich das ist ich
dachte ich wäre harry potter 107 fact
12,1 und ein konkreter machen euch zu
einem echten minecraft experten ich an
expert ich hab das ja es recht seltenen
videos gesagt sondern meistens eher auf
twitter gepostet wenn es irgendwelche
fortschritte bezüglich seiten layout
design themen youtuber die auch in dem
kunst und ez er allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht ich mach ein video weil wenn
jedes video seht kommt das buch morgen
raus um euch mal einen kurzen überblick
darüber zu geben habe ich mir gedacht
ich machen wie wir uns weil wir können
einfach mal ich will nicht das ganze
buch zeigen weil es wird sonst keinen
sinn ergeben wir machen einfach mal
stoppt irgendeiner seite sagt okay hier
machen wir hier stoppt jeder andere
beispielsweise eine typische seite aus
dem buch 33 der ramadan perfekt ihren 13
ist das da erklärt und da steht dann
immer so bei der nasa ist gewissermaßen
die hölle von minecraft leben
es ist blöd ich kann ich auf dem kopf
lesen lohn sind mops aus dem nenner die
als extrem heiß dargestellt werden sie
kommen ja aus der hölle los mit einem
starken schwer zu bekämpfen kann
sinnvoll sein das kommt aber auch das
schwert an
man kann es sich aber auch einfach
machen bla bla bla und erklärt diesen
tag mit den lohn
ja das ist seite 84 jetzt gewesen das
buch besteht hauptsächlich aus minecraft
sachen also aus pécs et cetera
allerdings sind da auch ein paar
einzelne sachen über mich drin da finde
ich jetzt aber natürlich wieder auf die
schnelle nichts da haben wir doch eine
seite gefunden fakten über mich da sind
beispielsweise ein paar sachen drin
über milch so was mein mikro ist warum
ich mit youtube angefangen habe was ich
für beleuchtung benutze was meine
lieblingsfarbe ist meiner
lieblingsstädte dann gibt es noch andere
sachen wo beispielsweise
urlaubsgeschichten drin sind hiervon
beispielsweise max und mia wir haben im
urlaub zusammen waren und so weiter und
so fort dann habt ihr unter anderem auch
hinten noch ein autogramm drin
allerdings ist es beim autogramm so dass
wir es nur in die erste auflage packen
das ist irgendwie nicht anders möglich
ich weiß nicht warum auf jeden fall ist
eine erste auflage programm hinten drin
irgendwie so zum ausschneiden oder so
also dass mein name da da das bin ich
das ist nur der erste auflage drin das
heißt wenn ihr ein haben möchtet ich
weiß nicht wie schnell die erstauflage
weg sein
jetzt kann sein dass keiner von euch das
buch kaufen wird es kann sein dass das
ganze direkt am ersten tag weg sein wird
deswegen nicht böse sein wenn ihr euch
das buch irgendwie preis nicht wert in
dem monat geburtstag gehabt und kauft
euch das buch deshalb erst einen monat
bekommt es dann geschenkt nicht böse
sein falls dann kein autogramm drin habt
letztendlich ist das kein buch wo ich
mir irgendeine geschichte ausgedacht
habe weil ich war auch damals im
deutschen auftrag schreiben als auftrag
es heißt aufsatz gut luca ich war noch
nie gut darin hängt einen aufsatz zu
schreiben oder irgendwas auszudenken
deswegen haben wir quasi einfach alles
möglich ihr zusammen gewürfelt wo ich
mir gedacht habe das möchte ich mal
irgendwie verschriftlicht haben so wird
der komplette inhalt aus als sie kann
doch einfach eine buchhandlung gehen und
euch das mal anschauen kannst auch bei
amazon bestellen da packe ich euch den
link mal
in die genau wir haben alles mögliche
drin wie alles begann also ich wirklich
auf youtube bekommen will dann so einen
pvp strategien unter anderem eine tolle
strategie
allerdings sind da noch strategien von
anderen youtube drin wie beispielsweise
glaube ich von sturm es ist etwas drin
von roth pilz vom bombenattrappe auf was
ein anderes thema in minecraft noch
bezogen auf jeden fall damit auch andere
youtuber mit drin und halt auch so
sachen meine lieblingsgames meine
lieblings youtuber dann ist quasi alles
ob ihr findet auf den meisten seiten
wirklich irgendwelche minecraft facts
einfach relativ viele command sind auch
noch drin und wir haben wir versucht
natürlich viele fans aus videos zu
nehmen damit die nummer verschriftlicht
habt also aus der kompletten minecraft
werk serie wie auf dem kanal
allerdings haben wir ich glaube ein
drittel oder so haben beweglich auch
neue macs genommen die ich noch nicht
vorgestellt hatte
die wir irgendwie anderweitig gefunden
haben selbst aus gefunden haben damit
das quasi nicht einfach nur
verschriftlichung von meinen videos ist
es ist wirklich zusammen gewürfelt ich
habe jetzt gerade einfach eine seite
wieder aufgeschlagen ist die seite
shader einfach wo ich meine lieblings
shader erkläre oder eine seite weiter
creepy shader wohl die shader drin sind
die frau das ist aber echt abartig aus
dieser schilder deswegen freunde
erwartet gar keinen blockbuster thriller
roman whatever sondern es ist wirklich
einfach nur das worauf ich bock hatte
habe ich gesagt ja das will ich da rein
fakten und das habe ich in meinen worten
geschrieben und nicht irre wie mich zu
ihm was ab zwingen lassen oder das sind
wirklich meine worte da drin und es wird
bei den vielen sätzen noch mehr anklang
will das ist ab sofort erhältlich in
allen buchhandlungen
und auch bei amazon sie findet wie
gesagt links in der beschreibung und was
ich auch noch sagen wollte war wenn ihr
euch so ein buch gekauft habt oder auch
nicht oder ihr wollt euch eins kaufen
oder ihr wollt mich einfach nur sehen
oder ihr wollt einfach ein autogramm
dann machen wir eine autogrammstunde in
der mayerschen buchhandlung in köln am
september von 14 bis 15 uhr also merken
26 september 14 bis 15 uhr in der
mayerschen buchhandlung in köln
da geben krankhafte also max und ich
kommen dahin setzen uns dahin geben euch
irgendwie autogramme in das buch rhein
oder irgendwo anders hin oder her wollte
ich das buch kaufen da und dann können
wir das da signieren oder keine ahnung
was also sollen signierstunde lava
stunde es geht allerdings wirklich nur
von 14 bis 15 uhr beim maxi nicht danach
zum poker event müssen von let's play
poker denkst das heißt wenn ihr da
wirklich dran kommen möchte pc mich
treffen möchte müsste jetzt glaube ich
echt schon früh da sein also ich weiß
nicht wie viele leute kommen kann auch
sein dass wir alle sagt nö meinen
samstag will ich eigentlich lieber mit
was anderem verbringen als diesen spaß
doch noch in real life zu sehen aber das
ist ihr euch selbst überlassen ich bin
auf jeden fall am 26 september das ist
in drei tagen meine ich da bin ich in
der mayerschen von 14 bis 15 uhr in köln
mit max und wir werden dort autogramme
geben fotos mit euch machen ja könnt ihr
auch das buch dann mit autogramm kaufen
habe ich jetzt glaubt bauer nein die
softbox ist kurz vor morgen fallen sonst
will ich euch wieso klatschen team am
ende des videos ich will euch gar nicht
lange aufhalten ich wollte euch nur
sagen mein buch ist draußen und es ist
so geil dass ich wirklich machen konnte
also ich weiß nicht dass 40 tore im
video ist auch immer so ein kleines baby
was man auf dem pc hat aber so ein buch
ist einfach so kannst du so festhalten
weißt du ja das habe ich gemacht
es ist so schön und so
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns dann in
drei tagen in der mayerschen oder auch
nicht oder ihr seht mich gar nicht oder
ich euch und tschüss